welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name's Hisham azuz today I'm
I've been really looking forward to this
conversation and I'm really delighted to
introduce all of you to a guy called
Chevy Roth who works in recruitment for
ten years working in agency for a two
years internal and for the last five
years
Chevy's actually been a well-being and
productivity coach working with people
from all walks of life but professionals
and corporates and really excites have
your own Chevy I'm excited to be here
brother like I really am thanks thanks
for having me yeah I'm really excited
for all the listeners to me and know who
you are so don't already so look we're
always like to start on on this podcast
is is how you got into recruitment and
but before I do what how have things
been for you what's been what's been
going on in the Chevy world for the last
couple of months I think it's like you
know like a lot of us highs and lows
things to be grateful for things to
stress about you know energy to spend
trying to navigate this new world that
we live in yeah man I always I say you
know it's been I can't say I mean we're
recording this at what the the end of
June now so I've actually taken June off
because you know and I kind of always
say this because you know I'm the
well-being productivity and energy guy
right like I'm the guy that helps people
understand how to get more out of their
day whether that's more time with loved
ones more time for themselves more
energy from somewhere maybe in us you
know I live and breathe this stuff and
you know I burn out right like or
whatever we want to call it you know
it's it's really important to share that
so I've just you know got to the kind of
end of end of May beginning of June and
I was like you know what I'm done with
pivoting right now and I'm gonna take
some time out so I've just kind of been
putting some energy back in the tank and
just kind of letting some of the lessons
let's and then just kind of right what's
phase two now because we're only just
beginning really so it's kind of you
know what does that look like so I'm
kind of in a good space it's a few days
it got hard but other than that spoken
to a lot of people that
who have their own business of sort of
use this time to sort of deal on the
business things and reflect and think
about what they like to think how they'd
want the next for a couple of months to
look like but okay awesome
well I think as you know and mean you
discussed we're definitely gonna touch
on chevy rough recruitment recruitment
career we're gonna definite up the map
but I think what what I'm really keen to
talk about and focus on today is sort of
Chevy's journey and becoming a well
being productivity coach water you sort
of the common things you see in people
this little journey that you've been on
yourself and yeah have a real focus and
open discussion around mental well-being
yeah so let's just start with how how
you entered the world of recruitment
because it's a big part of your life so
how did how did you get into recruitment
you know I don't wanna be another
another recruiter i Bobet I talk about
myself still is if I'm a recruiter
I always like I work with the
recruitment companies now I'm kind of
like I'm sitting there presenting to
young guys and people and and and I'm
like I'm talking like I'm on the sales
floor still like holding on to something
gorgeous that kind of comes on in quite
a maradi but I dare I say you know like
were most fell into the industry you
know it was it was never a childhood
dream to be a recruitment consultant and
it was saying I am really heard of until
properly until kind of like my early 20s
so I mean I left school at like 16 I I
fell out the public school education you
know my mom always says she'd been
better investing in the house then than
my education but it was I kind of fell
out at school and I went to work in the
square mile for four years so I were
actually worked in kind of back-office
operations then trade support I work for
like Credit Suisse Cantor Fitzgerald
kind of brokerage didn't approve what I
was doing like I'm pretty sure there's a
piece of paper that leads back to me
that's responsible for the credit crunch
massively dyslexic you know but within
that dyslexia that I suppose I started
to understand how to navigate your way
through your career through
communication
relationships as opposed to kind of you
know being the guy that could put
together the great debt do you know what
I mean might be the numbers person - I
did that I didn't understand what I was
doing and they you know unfortunately I
got into that trap thing where I kind of
got to 2122 and I'd learn great money
you know I was earning fantastic money
but didn't really understand what I was
doing wasn't really good at it never
really felt like I fit into the city in
that capacity in the finance world had a
lot of impostor syndrome going on so I
kind of took a year out or six months
out I think like so long ago I'm trying
to remember like I'm sure that my facts
on check facts and figures checks me
I'll be a little bit false but it was
like you know I took like six months out
or something a common band I was like I
still need to have the same earning
potential that's where I got stuck right
like you know there's only good money
and I wanted to keep earning that and
kind of people had identified in me that
that I was good at building
relationships that's how I got ahead in
my career within you know financial
services that's why I got paid the
bonuses that I got paid because the
relationships by Bill so someone just
naturally and organically said
recruitment to me and I think I ended up
knocking on the door of Hudson with
those guys and they were kind of like we
need to mess up we need a junior
researcher associate consultant come
work on our newly Pollock qualified
accountant desk so chipping
newly-qualified ACA is out of practice
in some kind of middle office banking
operation office planet front office
functions so yeah I did that dude I was
just like cool you know no I sell the
dream right you've got earning potential
autonomous building a business everyone
was wearing shiny watches and shiny
suits and I was 22 years old and thought
yeah I won the holiday so I beat her and
the the shiny cars that's what I needed
my that's what's gonna make me happy so
how how would you sum up your time and
equipment drug-fueled
and a real battle it was you know I you
know there's school reports and I think
a lot you know I speak to adding a lot
of consultants you know over the years
I've met you know it's kind of like chef
chef did chip could do really good in
school but you know chef has an accent
right like but like and I think like I
have no doubt there are people you know
you've got a good podcast here it has a
good reach and I have no doubt that
there'll be people listening to this
potentially that will know someone that
I know that knew me from back of the day
and they'd be like yeah yeah he was a
good guy but right like my name carried
fast right like Chevy Roth like is
unfortunately everything to get a
blessing and a curse in life like and it
was um so I you know I I was a very lost
young man I think to give some context I
know you want to talk about mental
health today so let me give people a
little bit of context here when I walked
into the city I had been bullied at
school I never fitted into the
playground and I struggled with saying
no and especially no to men because my
dad had kind of walked out of the house
at the age of 12 and you know I never
really knew how to fit in with guys in
the playground you know I was always
really uncomfortable with that I never
really underlight didn't like football
and I found it hard so I became this
chameleon I wore this mask right like it
was like I learned to like the football
team that you like you know I learned to
like the music that you liked right you
don't I mean like oh you listen to the
Fugees to score right then I'm going
home so is this kind of like this this
this this creating and wearing a mask
that I felt other people wanted me to
wear to be accepted by them so when I
rolled into the city at 18 when I went
down the pub with a bunch of traders and
they were like what do you want to drink
and I was like I'll have an orange juice
and they're like no you won't you'll
have a pint of Stella and then you'll
have a double vodka redbull and you'll
learn to love it I didn't want to say no
right like I said yes because I wanted
them to accept me into their tribe and
what I found through alcohol and alcohol
led to drugs led to coke very quickly
and what I found is these substances
gave me superhero powers they gave me
confidence they gave me identity within
the pack I could be trusted to be the
last man standing on the dance floor you
could trust me to go and dance with the
girls and chat to the girls and like it
gave me this mask to wear and this
identity so when I rolled into
recruitment
boy right like we all know what the
industry you know it's definitely trying
to change but we understand it's an
industry like many other industries
where there can be a big work hard play
hard culture like it's the way so I
gravitated towards that so then the more
I got into recruitment the more I sunk
into my addiction but then my cycle with
recruitment was feeding the addiction
from a fitting in point of view an
identity point of view but also from a
financial point of view so I would bust
quarterly targets I would be like you
know hundred plus quarter 120 plus
quarter like I would be breaking targets
from my market breaking records on the
teams like I would be hunting people
down and then I would get the money in
my account and then I would spend the
following quarter spending that on
partying and drugs dipping so my career
was I was the worst kind of consultant
you could have which was no consistency
really no I mean like and we all notice
like many a new thing that was a direct
correlation with your lifestyle it was
no I think it was it was a couple of
factors it was one lifestyle and also
secondly I felt like I didn't understand
the purpose of my life and what I was
doing
I understood the mechanics of
recruitment and I got value from being a
consultant as opposed to as a Sharky
salesman for lack of a better phrase I
understood that if I treated my
candidates right whether I place them or
didn't place them that would lead to
future business where there is a hiring
manager or referrals or their future
bitten future movement I understood
these mechanics but I didn't I felt like
recruitment was flipping burgers at
Burger King you know why have I got to
do these BT calls why am I going through
this suffering why am i dealing with
deals dropping out like what's the point
of me doing this I had no purpose
attached to my job and I also worked for
organizations that stripped autonomy you
know it was getting at eight-thirty like
you know 8:29 like and be on the phones
an hour by hour and as human beings if
you remove autonomy and you remove
purpose people struggle right like in as
human beings we need to feel in control
of our life and we need to feel like we
have a purpose I had neither of those so
when you have the drugs that were
compounding on childhood trauma and
compounding on living a life that I
didn't understand and didn't really want
to do and didn't really kind of get I
just had this relationship with
recruitment that was highs and lows and
then as the addiction got darker I mean
it was a stage when I had more jobs than
you've had hot dinners and I used to
just my CV was [ __ ] because I
understood the mechanics of having to
move from agency to agency better pay
rise but not actually like I knew how to
sell to people right like say you know
and I'm not proud of that and I'm
laughing about I'm not proud of it like
I'm not that I'm just giving the reality
to mental health at the time which was
survival yeah so I had that and then to
finish off Cerrone I'm waffling then to
finish off the last few years I like I
was proud of what I did then I started
to build a reputation and name and and
started to deliver and find consistency
and do well so I caused a lot of damage
to my reputation for the beginning years
I was very up and down but then as I
started to clean up sober up get
drug-free I started to build a career
that I was proud of and I delivered for
the people that I worked with and you
know hopefully they led to this day
they'll say they were proud to have me
on their team which I'm proud of and I
developed good consultants in the end so
I was happy with that
did anyone did anyone ever pull you so
and go Chevy
well done Greg quarter smashed it when I
was in your shoes look I have have fun
do you wanna do but like I've got some
advice for you I met what you should
think about with your money like did
anyone ever have that conversation with
me this is what I'm really looking
forward to the conversation with you bro
because these are such important like
that you've just nailed like I think
what is such an important conversation
to have to help shift the culture of
recruitment or for us to play a part in
that conversation and whatever small
where is in short no they didn't you
know and I think people tried like in
all fairness maybe people tried but I
was so in my own ego and my own [ __ ]
that I've just rejected it really
quickly and I'm sure that there were
people in my career that turned around
and tried to give me some fatherly
advice do you know what I mean but I
think generally 99% of the people that I
worked with were fuel to my fire you
know and this is a thing like we've got
to remember an industry and there are
other industries
like this but generally you know
recruitment was an industry where
researchers junior graduates were doing
cocaine and toilets and hotel rooms with
MDS and CEOs and I you know it brought
straight facts like straight fact and I
will come at the recruitment market
there are a lot of agencies that are
really trying to evolve but there are
still a lot of agencies stuck in this
because you've got a lot of MDS and CEOs
or senior managers who are in this
career in this life of earned the money
haven't got an exit plan not really
finding a purpose in what they do and
driven by what they do so they become
kings in their own court right yeah and
I see this play out like I see it in
junior people now consultants I see in
agencies that I go in and talk to when I
look at their culture and whether I'm
gonna work with them or not and I see
this and then what they're doing is
they're playing out in their own court
and then they're feeding it you know I'm
gonna win sent advise you by giving you
Commission but I'm also gonna give you a
couple of bags of coke and take you down
the strip club at 12 o'clock on a Friday
at the end of the quarter and that was
definitely I mean that's a coach was
definitely shifting but that was the
culture of recruitment that I was in
hard and fast so it was just you know I
was the guy getting the drugs in for my
director so there was no financial
conversation right which I think will go
into the financial health mental health
they're linked
dude no exactly bro cuz its well-being
right what are the different elements of
well-being you know we've got social
well-being physical well-being mental
well-being environmental well-being and
I'm talking about our environments not
plastic like you've got all these things
and then yes financial well-being is a
huge huge factor and you know no one is
given and this is private like good
companies now off the packages to young
people to help them understand how to
manage their finances as you know kids
of 20 to 23 or are yeah I mean some can
be earning 30 grand some can be earning
50 60 70 and if they're a player they're
earning a hundred K 110k within the
first few years by the age of 25 26
you're balling in all this money and no
one's helped you understood how to spend
that money you know so it's definitely I
mean no one had that conversation it was
definitely you know just to finish why I
think it's so important because of the
reasons but I just think that you know
this is when I try and work now with
senior consultants principal consultants
managers and so forth I'm like
you know it's not just about what money
you can bring to the business is also
how you can uplift the culture of the
business and and the market as a whole
you know junior consultants are looking
up to you so if you want to know how to
help people in your company and help
challenge the culture of recruitment or
sales and so forth then you get the
opportunity to be a role model and then
it gives them purpose right like it's
great so this is kind of this get this
system that we can create anyway I'm
waffling but yeah no no I like that so
what I want to talk a bit about then
before we go into this over the last
five years is so far if I'm listening
right now and I've recognized that I'm
in those circles right it's a Bachelor
point of it's so hard to say no yes
especially when you're in a business you
don't wanna be that guy that leaves the
pub early you don't wanna be that guy
that orders orange juice because you get
more grief for it
you like it's just how it is right I'm
not drinking today now come on come on
that's a lie
so like fun if I've if I'd recognized
that I'm in these circles and I'm sort
of thinking you know what whenever I've
ended up going out with Chevy after work
it's always gone a bit Pete Tong and
that's something that I'm trying to sort
of fizzle out of my life because I am
trying to work out what my purpose is
and they're so like that so II it's it's
hard to sort of get away from that so I
guess what I'm the sort of you to share
is like how you started to like you said
like by the end of your career you was
actually ended he was really proud of
what you did bla bla bla so how what was
that transition like what was driving it
and how did you start actually getting
out of that dark place very good really
great question really important question
because I can sometimes be very
reductionist like very black and white
like this is what you need to do right
but there's a lot of gray area to this
and change and improving your health and
well now I decided to quit drugs 12
years ago I'm still dealing with the
echoes of that addiction today right
like is improving your well-being in
your health and your behaviors and your
habits is about how can I make 2 to 3%
games this year and how does that
compound them next year the year after
that year after that there is no switch
where you go from one to the other
there are definitely significant moments
in your life but absolutely it's not as
easy as that it's a lot about two steps
forward five steps back on occasion so
the couple of bits of advice I give is
in one we can look at the research
behind this and look at some
evidence-based stuff from it and give
some real quick highlight of that
actually just from a personal
perspective and when I'm working with
people trying to make this transition
and change in life is you've got to
first separate the difference between
your kind of inside view and inside
noise so your inside view is constantly
telling you what you need to do in life
right like how many people have said in
the last couple of months that they
really need a holiday because they're
they're non conscious they're the mean
years of evolution their system is
actually saying to them like probably
you've spent a lot of energy over the
last couple of months I need you to take
a break right now right like our inside
view is constantly saying I should
probably get back to the gym I need to
start healthier I should have more we're
constantly telling ourselves what we
need I should probably head home tonight
but what happens is inside noise gets in
the way like I don't want to miss out
I've got FOMO like careers are made down
the pub last one in first first one in
last one out right like we have this
noise that just kind of suppresses that
inside view and that's also fed by
outside noise which is culture you know
like culture kind of is talking about
hustle cultures and you know you've got
to be you know anyway blah blah and I
think first of all is to distinguish
between the two and start to really
build a strength of character and belief
in your inside view and actioning that
inside view and you know stepping over
some of your own [ __ ] about well why do
I feel I have to go down the pub you
know and realizing that you're gonna
have to probably have some tough
conversations with yourself around why
that is because I want to fit in I want
to be accepted like conversations that
you might not have with anyone else but
you're gonna need to have with yourself
to understand why you feel you need to
be in the pub maybe you just want to be
in the pub because you hate your job so
much you just want to forget right
that's the hardest part though right who
who's willing to admit or look at the
pots that don't like about themselves
yeah and this I mean and that's it and
that's what you know my job is to put a
mirror up to people right and
that's what I do is get them looking at
these hard questions and and and so
forth but this is the work you have to
do vote for me so there was a couple of
things these important is because it was
one just one it was really like the
first thing the first step that I took
was realizing as not putting a gold
standard of myself and what change
looked like for years I spent my life
wishing I was like other people and
being happy like other people having the
cars like other people the houses I
people I was always wishing myself into
another life and the first thing yeah
comparing right like it's there is the
you know the the thief of joy right it's
comparison it's like and for me I
stopped and just thought you know what I
need to stop thinking about the bigger
picture because I can't see the road
ahead at the moment what I need to do is
focus on today what are the small things
that I can do today to impact today and
tomorrow and how can I start to create
these habits and routines and I started
small I made my problem small I made my
world small I stopped thinking about the
bigger stuff and I focused on today and
I learned to say no you know and I
learned to accept that if I did say yes
and I went and did a few grams of coke
and I didn't sleep that night and I was
back in work the next morning I refuse
to call myself a failure instead I took
a growth mindset where I thought what
did I learn from this where did I go
wrong what should have I listen to it in
myself it was for me it was for me what
sparked that was was hitting rock bottom
you know it was realizing I was I was
like you know it was Christmas Day
morning and I was wrapping presents at
6:00 am surrounded by cocaine with the
family or coming over for the rest of
the day and I'd been up for four days
straight dipping into a twenty grand
commission bonus right like I had cloud
about for five grand out of 20 grand in
it in a couple of days like I just got
paid a big big boy bonus right so for me
it was like I was like I knew I'm gonna
kill myself
if I don't start to make change so real
live moment yeah and I was an I did no
self help I didn't even know the
conversation about mental health then I
just had enough in me to realize I knew
that I was meant for more and maybe that
more love for myself more of a happier
life or what I just knew there was
something different I'm sure when you
were working recruitment you had these
justesen feeling inside you that
something more is out there yeah and
rock bottom moment that encouraged to
hold a mirror up which was like this
this isn't the person that I want to be
and I did that and then I just started
saying no and here's a couple of bits of
advice is one your career is not made
down the pub you actually start to get a
hell of a lot of respect from your
colleagues and your peers and your
managers when you're rolling in full of
energy when they're full of share and if
you want to be a good consultant if you
want to be a good salesman your job is
not just to meet men make money it's to
elevate the team in the business around
you is to bring the energy up of a sales
floor that's struggling to get moving
and when you're the person on the phones
first thing in the morning and everyone
around you isn't you start to stand out
and even when you're not doing and
that's what you start to get more credit
in the bank with people around you so
for me and and then people start to
respect you and then people start to see
that change and they kind of want to
know well how's he doing this I would
like to know this and then for me and
this is the most important thing when
people try and create change they try
and remove things from their life
without filling that void with anything
else so for me like just going home
wasn't good enough because when you
haven't replaced what that pub was
giving you or what it was or going out
was with something else you just ended
up retreating back to old habits so for
me I was lucky I found running and that
kind of an exercise and fitness became
something that I could go and do instead
of yeah and it's and that's the thing
you've got to feel like and then for me
the circum bit too that was because all
my boys were down the pub getting
smashed and that was my I suddenly
became very friendly syn London and I'm
from London born and bred but I was
lucky because I found a community
through running and I used to meet up
with them every week and they became
friends that I traveled with so I filled
the human interaction I got down the pub
with another community and that was
pivotal to my consistent ongoing change
because that was gonna be my next thing
right how important are friends in this
suit in this change and help and
influence that and because I think
that's also really hard part as well cuz
yeah that actually that's something I've
been from my own sort of journey but I
think that's one of the hardest parts
people have with this is that are but on
that means I'm not gonna be other no
like yeah who's Who am I then going to
have that human connection with if I'm
not going down to the pub with Chevy
like I think it's you'll really like
that insight is you got replace it with
something you can't just leave the gap
there because it reversed old habits
but I think that friend parts
interesting because that's really hard
yeah that is like that is so thus like
you've all be proud you've got to be
proactive if you want to change your
environment within the environment in
some of the friends you hang around with
and things like that and that's not
difficult not an easy and I think
there's a couple of things to firstly
understand is is let's understand from a
physiological point of view how we
respond to social connection and humans
around us like when if we were in a room
talking right now and we're connecting
our heart rates and respiratory mate
rates would start to mirror each other
yeah bro like you like our physiology is
set up to bring us closer to other human
beings right hands up who's ever been
stressed and asked their mum right I
need a cuddle from a mother I need a
cuddle from myself I need a cuddle for
whoever that is because from a
physiological point of view if you're
stressed you're not just releasing
adrenaline and cortisol you're also
probably releasing a higher amount of
oxytocin oxytocin is the love hormone
which designed to bring you closer to to
get to other human beings a lot of
people your natural stress response is
drawing closer to humans because
evolution has said you're closer you're
safer as a tribe then you walk out in
the wilderness by yourself here's the
second thing
your brains default mode is social
cognition so the reason that you try and
close your eyes and meditate and you
can't because you're thinking about
everything in the world and your
relationships it's not because you're
broken it's because your brains just
trying to process your relationships
with other people in the world because
the brains default mode is thinking
about our place and us in a pack in a
social situation right so we're designed
to be part of a tribe to be close to
other human being so when you rip that
out of your life because they're all
you've got is that connection down the
pub of course you're gonna go back
because you're stressed you're sad and
then your default body mode is to say
you need to be close to your tribe where
are your tribe in the pub right so I
think first of all just understand
battle that you've got about that the
second thing to think about is well
first of all the quality quantity over
quality over quantity is what counts
when it comes to Friendship no you don't
need 50 friends I genuinely probably
have about to because I think yeah I
speaking to my friends about this last
night and I think that's all for me
personally that's also been I think that
can also be a bit of a challenge for me
personally right and I'll explain what I
mean is that when you sort of gone
through that transition and if you're
listening you sort of recognize that
well actually when I've gone out of that
person it always ends up going a bit
weird and I want to sort of avoid that
blah blah blah like for me personally
and now when I like meet new people or
I'm looking at sort of yeah potentially
have make new friendships like my bar is
quite high yeah do you get my I mean so
like actually so that I found that
sometimes having a bit of a conflict
that when you've recognized that that
quality over quantity then there's also
a bit of a conflict there where it's
like when you do meet new people bah
blah blah and others it but just a bit
of a standard where for me he personally
a friendship is if I'm gonna go down the
spend time with Chevy and you're my
friends
lot I should I have my mindset should be
or how I should feel towards that is
that I'm going and shared like Chevy's
actually gonna add something to it like
when me and Chevy meet he's actually had
something not take away I don't walk
away from that I was spending time
together thinking [ __ ] I'll feel more
stressed after that or they've just
always just unleashed all their pain
onto me or whatever lie on so I think
yeah the quality over quantity things
really interesting and for me a person
I've always liked you can you can tell a
bit judgmental but you can tell those
that have quantity over quality from a
friendship standpoint I think she's
interesting because you can you always
see these people sort of one minute
they're you soon from this circle
friends and they're that so-called
friends and I think it'd be really
interesting to actually know like like
do they know who their friends are and I
think that yeah the quality of the
concept I couldn't agree that more
that's something that's really helped me
amazing very amazing brain there so
that's it like and that's what I think I
you know I had to learn that over a long
period of time but it's you know so then
it's kind of him and I'm coaching people
through change at the moment it's like
well
oh yeah you might not go out and
Thursday night but why don't you go and
arrange like a coffee or a walk or a
lunch or a bike ride or you know pick up
game or something on a Saturday with
your your best mate
with your mate right there's always
people in your past that you feel that
you should be connecting with more that
kind of you're drawn towards it gives
you an opportunity so it's just thinking
about where are the two or three
relationships or the one relationship
that I can nurture you know and
realizing it's not about having 50 mates
as we've said it's nurturing those one
or two mates and then realizing the rest
is an exploration you know as you start
to have energy back again as you start
to create time in your life to be able
to spend on you then it's about you know
where maybe I'm gonna go join this
sports team or maybe I'm gonna join this
community or this class and just getting
different engagements and interaction it
takes time taking me a decade to build
anew on that point which i think is
really important for anyone listening is
light and you've got to be proactive
that's why I've recognized like you it
this this like if you're someone that
feels like you haven't got loads of
quality mates and it's something that
you want unfortunate that means you do
have to get bit uncomfortable and you
have to be proactive like that's
definitely what I've that I've really
learned that in London when that means
up here with like you have to be but you
have to actually do stuff just business
development but it is like you've
already demonstrated the skills that you
need which is just consistency in
resilience and and and you know a growth
mindset of like learning through each
step lists you know and just it just
takes time and put the numbers in put
time in and it will start to occur but
like I said just start with people close
to you and here's the thing like the
more energy you have the less tired you
are the more quality you can bring to
the conversation so what do people can
bring to your life and imagine like how
much more focused you can be on your
loved ones and your family when you're
not sitting there on a comedown or
hanging out your ass or whatever it may
be or exhaust it or that when you're
more present you're gonna feel the
quality of your air energy that you can
give to them it is gonna elevate them
and then that gives you a satisfaction
and the self-worth and that's really
invest half of it it's not them for them
to please you it's also what you can
give to them and actually when we can
help other people that's really great
for our health and well-being
so just because I think it is such a
good insight and good
so if I'm listen right now and I'm gone
yet that's really interesting Chevy that
I yeah I do want to do let's drink and I
do wanna do less time down the pub and I
don't demonize the pub here I love going
down the path but yeah it's like that's
we're talking about sort of them it's
that that's always been this or catalyst
of you ended up in the dark place or
whatever
I think the insight around you've got a
replace is really interesting so find
this one I'm like right I've got a
replace this I hate running that I'm not
going to do that so like what's your
advice to people because I'm sure you
have this a lot it's like how what do
you say to people to sort of encourage
them like how can I find that
replacement like what should I be doing
the first thing that you've got I think
we've got to think about is if it's
someone is in situation where they want
to make change they're probably really
stressed really tired really exhausted
and coming from a place of debt so I
credit is it what debt is it word you
know what I mean like we I've got to get
back to square one before I kind of move
forward I'm like here and you know later
so I think you've got to think about
that so then we've got to think about
keeping things easy and think ppb's
keeping things simple and there's also
the reality is that if you've been the
pub a lot if you've been partying a lot
if you're kind of constantly tired or if
you just kind of have been maybe here we
go let's be straight if you've been
running away from [ __ ] for a long time
and you've just not really been dealing
with your whatever you've got going on
you're gonna need some time to process
that right and here's the thing like our
social brains needs solitude they need
to have time away from everything right
and it's not being on social media
that's not scrolling through news right
like not listening to podcast we need
time to actually just be in our own
thoughts we and that when we do that we
start to process we started to get
access to different cognitive resources
better decision-making creativity right
so the first bit of advice I'd give to
people is it doesn't have to be the gym
because maybe you haven't gotten the
energy you don't have to sign up for a
marathon because maybe you haven't got
any energy yet to sign up to a course
because maybe you haven't got enough
energy it's just starting to create some
time in your life where you can spend
some time by yourself processing
whatever [ __ ] you've got going on or
you've been moving away from
so simply looking at things like walking
during lunch breaks without podcasts on
for half an hour 45 minutes getting off
the train or if you're working from home
right now get ready for work in the
morning go for your commute and that
commute can be a 30-minute walk around
your neighborhood and then turn up at
your desk at work in your house right
like transitioning between work and home
like going for a thirty 45-minute
commute to process the day because when
you start to close down the energy
cycles of the day energy cycles can be
this podcast they can be checking emails
meetings whatever when you start to
close down these mini stress and energy
cycles these little moments of time that
cause us to spend more energy and cause
us to just be in the game when you do
that you start to process you know so
putting in commutes putting in walks
lunch times going for a walk after work
going for a long walk on the weekend
because that'll just give you time to
process and think and then once you've
caught up with your thinking you can
then start to think about the future to
make something scared no that makes
sense what if I'm scared if I'm scared
of thinking what if I'm scared of my own
I'm sure there's been times in your life
when you've been scared before but
you've stepped over it and you've
learned from it you know someone's
scared about something I challenge you
to think about a time in your life that
something has scared you and as opposed
to walking away from it you've lent into
it that could be the first BD call that
you've ever done right like I laugh at
seasoned recruiters who struggle with a
ship because I'm like you have you've
already demonstrated all the skills that
you need to do this right or you're
scared of doing something you're scared
of leaning into something that makes you
feel uncomfortable how do you think
you've got to billing and for half a
million a year like Juno or whatever it
was like you lent into things that
scared you so think about a time that
you've think of the behavior one think
about time that you've demonstrated that
behavior in the past take confidence
from that and just lean the hell in and
realize that as human beings the place
that we learn is when we're slightly
frustrated or there is struggle right we
don't learn during the good times we do
we can learn from books and studying
that's all great but you know what we
learn from picking up the phone and life
experience and we learn through struggle
and frustration that's where we're
primed from plasticity from our brains
point of view to make the best adaptions
so actually feeling a little bit scared
is a signal that that's the thing that
you need to lean into you know when I'm
talking to
since about how to manage your day and
I'm talking about what times a day they
should be doing [ __ ] they're like first
thing I see them just pissing about
checking emails doing all the easy stuff
all the stuff that's okay and writing
lists and all that Mike what's the thing
that scares you the most today is making
this call right that's the first thing
that you're gonna do because for so many
reasons that's where you're gonna get
the most value you know so it's kind of
just leaning in because that's quest
film yeah okay it's look for not the
final thing but something that I
definitely want to sort of just cross
off here and then there'd be good to
talk about a bit more about the last
five years and your journey so we were
we were speaking about this before and
while so keen to do this like let's just
take the recruitment industry I think it
applies in our industries as well and
just in general but I think if we were
to look at odd finger be safe to say
that a lot of people that listen to this
podcast know that sort of mental
well-being mindset is important is a
challenge for a lot of people and I
think that's been a great shift over the
last couple years like how sort of
prominent is that we will know a lot of
people deal with it and a lot more
people talking about it but I think what
definitely lacks in the recruiting
industry is is men and Mayor was talking
about it right I think if you I've had
them all on the podcast run the Michelle
katieb Emma like I've had the great
people talk about who were on a mission
to really make mental health something
that is is normal to talk about whatever
normal is and it's a safe place to talk
about right particularly in recruits
there's a lot of female leaders driving
this conversation right but as a lot of
people will know or should know one of
the biggest killers of young men is
suicide is the mental health piece right
so like how how can we how can we
actually start like how can we actually
start encouraging men boys males to
actually start talking about this
because clearly like we're very impacted
by this but there isn't very many people
to look up to and sort of see or hear
guys talking about their men's mental
hardship and what they've gone through
and and I think part of that from my
experiences particularly in the south
and one recruitment environment
and how encouraged are you to open up
normally it's be perceived as a weakness
or like it's a sales testosterone heavy
environment so why would you show
weakness and that's not what you're
meant to do and all these things right
so I think there's loads of things but
but how can how can you start moving the
needle on that you think about how can
we start encouraging guys and men to
sort of be vulnerable and put their
guard down I think I kind of is an
amazing question I'm you me I'm sure we
could talk about this for hours it's
like it's it's so relevant and I think
the reason I kind of honey I left
recruitment like I never want to look at
recruitment again and now kind of
probably you know three chords and my
corporate work that I do is recruitment
agencies just because you know I think
I've still got some bones to pick with
the industry but one of the things that
I really want to do is is help young men
ambassador for men's mental health
charity and calm like it's such a big
important subject we appreciate the
question it's I think looking it from
two perspectives I think we always have
to think that any shift in culture comes
from two directions top-down bottom-up
and I'll explain this so first of all
like you know the how are we gonna do
this well the first thing nice that step
up is saying is talking to the CEO is
talking to the MDS talking to the
directors talking to the leadership
teams who are men and realizing that
they are role models in the young men
that are coming into this industry and
I've had like I have had Bulls out
hard-nosed conversations with CEOs who
I've said what you're doing is just not
cool you know like the culture that
you're creating is impacting young lives
of brains and young humans that are so
susceptible to this stuff and still
frittering out their place in the world
you know and I think it's got to come
from the top down they're the guys that
can really change culture they're the
guys who can really kind of create this
environment where it's okay to lead with
vulnerability and I'm not talking about
crying at your desk it's saying like hey
I've had a tough day today or hey I'm
worried about this month or hey I don't
think I think I'm gonna done' oh hey I'm
treating feeling pretty [ __ ] because I'm
bottom of the board you know like oh hey
it's okay to not go out for a drink stop
trying to you know let's embrace this
person running the marathon and not
trying to learn and back into the
doughnuts that we're leaving on top and
you know what I mean
I think he's that the young people that
we bring into this industry are looking
for signals and cues of how to behave
from the people above them right and you
know I think it's if there are three I'm
not telling people how to run their
business I'm just saying like hey you're
being looked up to and yes it is your
responsibility because you've hired
these human beings and they spend most
of their life with you and they've
fallen into an industry that they never
chose they wanted to do so you've got an
opportunity to impact them so I think
it's senior leadership teams looking at
how they're communicate communicating
the cues that they're sending people and
creating an environment where it's okay
to share and also watching the tone and
language of the things that are being
said you know yeah like the banter and
stuff like just being aware of it you
know what I mean like and and and I
think creating change slowly but surely
and getting advice and working with good
HR people and so forth and and creating
that cultural change so I think that's
one thing it's got to be from the top
down but here's the other one like I
always talk about I ask people like what
you wanna change around well being
within your organization or in us and
people always put it on the company on
the busses right like I want them to do
this I want them to do that I want them
to do this I'm like okay that's really
cool the business should be making the
change that you want and listening to
you but guess what guess who the
language of culture is you you're the
north's and ones of culture how you talk
to people is defining the culture of the
organization you're working in so for me
it's working with you know senior
consultants people who've been in the
business for a couple of years a few
years people who are moving up through
the ranks and working with them on how
to inspire the people around them how to
bring up the language and the tone and
the culture and the energy of the floor
how to inspire them you know how like
when a young man puts down a slams down
a phone call and he's calling that you
know like I'm going straight up right
like hanging up the phone call and he's
like stupid [ __ ] to a candidate now I
know that he's probably got some manners
and he's been bought up right but
because he's in a ladee culture he
thinks he can get away with saying that
right and people are talking about
candidates like they're pieces of meat
and not human beings at the other end of
the phone who are going through one of
the most stressful things that they've
been through if they're not calling you
back then you've failed because you
haven't got their attention or buy-in
it's not them dude you know and it's
like kind of then bringing up management
saying I actually don't accept that
language what look at what you're saying
you know and how is that influencing the
people around you we're in a new world
now you've got to step up and you've got
to be the language of change so for me
it's working with people that are looked
up to in the business and helping them
steer the language of change and
communication and talking and within
that that's things like mentorship
programs you know going in and talking
to a roomful of blokes around mental
health is never gonna work
because you've got a kind of sideswipe
Men right so it's just things like more
like you know in the month reviews like
we tend to do like you know how have I
done this month from weed sandwich it
right so how many times people sandwich
news you know it's like I'm gonna tell
you the bad and we'll tell you again
I'll tell you the bad again a word bad
good bad good or whatever but doing
things like actually take people into a
room and just talk about the good and
talk about the bad and constructive
feedback another time and maybe do that
positive talk on a walk outside of the
office and see if they start to open up
about other things so just changing how
you're talking about things the
environments you're talking in I could
go on forever doing like that so yeah
what you're saying quite simply is
definitely people that have influence in
the business we've got a lead from the
front and yeah they're role models and
then yeah I really like that what you
just said and then there's the
accountability the responsibility or if
you do want change then gonna have to
step up and you're gonna have to
actually make those changes yourself and
have a say and yeah I really like that
so just quickly on this and like I guess
what have been because I feel I'd like
to thing from the conversations are I'm
having a lot of business owners know
that they're role models and know this
is important or whatever and there will
still be people that may not think that
but like what have been some of the sort
of common things that have sort of kept
leaders paralyzed to trying to shift it
or change it I feel like what comes up
for me when you're talking about this is
that you'll say all this and go yeah
okay sherry I get I know it's important
but so what's what's working right now
what has worked have done really well
and I don't really want to change that
like what we've got going on right at
the moment is working is it's what we've
generated six million pounds and
turnover last year like not I don't see
how one that could help us make more
money or two why I want to change it so
that what have been the sort of common
things
you like these got these people that you
speak to our conscious of this important
but don't why aren't people take an
action do you think I think I think
first of all it's always injuries I'm
like I totally unlike it again I'm not
telling anyone how to run this yeah good
and I really just automatically guys now
and just try and be as black and white
in these conversations because I've got
an hour in a room to talk to each other
about it and I totally understand
there's different challenges and gray
areas you know first of all though it's
really interesting what you say is like
we don't want to and I'm like I have had
these conversations like whether you
want to or not you have to if you want
to attract and retain the best talent in
the market you need to be in this
conversation because generation whatever
letter we're up to in the alphabet that
I always forget their expectations are
clearly there we go
you know and it's expectations are
changing you only have to look at the
research around what their expectations
of you are as an employee moving forward
and if you're not doing these things if
you're not bringing well-being and
health and you know not making you know
we're so used to making time the metric
to success within recruitment it's not
as energy and focus you know it's not
about how many hours you put in it's
about being you know doing good with
what you know time you have and being
energized and being focused on that and
also making sure that people have energy
at the end of the day for themselves and
loved ones and they haven't given you
everything every day of the week every
week of the quarter and so forth you've
got to be in this conversation
especially now the country is going into
a big big hangover you know we are going
peoples energy levels are dropping
dramatically work is going to increase
I've seen this in a a you've seen how
people have dealt with it Inouye I've
seen it take them 2001 like you see the
hangovers and how tiring it is for
people to get out themselves out of the
holes people need to be in this
conversation at the moment it's so so
important the reason I see people not
doing this I think we to a question
forgive me another waffle through that
but I think that the thing that the
reason that I sees people struggling to
do this is because you have to put on
your own oxygen mask on before helping
other people and the companies that I
see really struggling to create this
kind of change are ones where senior
leadership teams are so [ __ ] stressed
out that they don't have the ability to
create this change yeah because they're
just hire it they're dis they're just
managers that are constantly looking for
the quickest solutions the best
solutions they're stressed and what do
we do women state of stress we focus on
the tiger in front of us we're not
thinking about the big
hit'em what we're going we're gonna pick
you know build our house and what what
crops working with focusing on the tiger
you know and we're focusing on staying
alive and this is what I see is
leadership teams when they are so
stressed and they're just fire fighting
all the time that is not a conversation
or time to be talking about strategic
growth or change around well-being or
mental health because they've got to
learn to look after their own [ __ ] first
manage their stress so they have the
cognitive resources to think about this
and implement it and again this might
come from the top you know sometimes
when I work with companies I work with a
CEO for a quarter on how to you know and
and their management team create change
there and then we trickle downwards yeah
okay all right so let's let's just set
away and talk a bit about more recent
times so as he left the recruitment
industry which I know you feel really
passionate about how it sort of equipped
you with so many skills experiences or
so really helped you do what you do now
but I think what's really interested to
talk about and you can saw give a bit of
context if you want but I know when we
spoke before this what I thought was
really interesting was really sort of
came to dig into because I think a lot
of people can relate was where you had
that experience where obviously yeah
left the recruitment industry then went
on to you or your new journey newfound
purpose and and you sort of got a bit of
success quite quickly ended up on a BBC
sort of documentary to do with running
and these types of things or see a lot
more people new Chevy ruff was and these
sorts of things and a few shared of me
how sort of these great things all
happen but and then you didn't feel
fulfilled or you got to that point where
you sort of was aiming for and where you
wanted to be and you got there and was
like and obviously didn't feel happy
didn't feel fulfilled so I guess it'd be
good to talk a bit about that it's gonna
give some context as to how you got to
that point that'd be great but what I
think that's important is because I
think that's really that will happen for
a lot of people that listen to this just
not just in recruitment but just in life
anyway and a few people were spoken
about this where had a guy called Nick
comm and that really and spoke really
open about this way sort of he got that
top Billa status he works absolute socks
off to get there he got it and then he
all of a sudden had a shoe
and he'll of new amount of pressure they
put himself and felt that all he was was
the top biller and if it wasn't that
what was he and went on a whole
different journey there so it wasn't
quite the experience before he was what
would have been yeah so you'd be good if
you could talk a bit about that because
I think that a lot of people I feel like
that to resume and help people yeah bro
it was them so ye I mean say that so I I
mean I left the I walked out on my job
like five just over five years ago went
traveling for a few months came back
retrained as a so I really originally
retrained as a personal trainer and
running coach and specialize with
working with runners and you have to
write like I got a call within the first
year of setting up my business my
coaching business from the BBC and they
said hey we got BBC one documentary two
parts the royal family are involved Nick
Knowles is presenting we want you to
coach ten people to run the London
Marathon that have mental health
conditions we want to connect the dots
between running and mental health and
this is when the sea change was
happening in 2016-17 it was heads
together and so forth that were
sponsoring the marathon so I went into
that project and when the most amazing
beautiful projects I ever did it was six
months of filming traveling around the
country working with these people who
the family now love them to pieces and
it was really ironic so I got to the as
the project started to because basically
the the documentary was gonna be aired
the the Thursday before the London
Marathon and then the second episode was
gonna be the Thursday after and I
started to kind of burn out and just
things weren't good for me coming
towards the end of the project but I
pushed on through kept going and the
irony was that I was on BBC on this
airing of the second episode I had
nailed the project to the wall I
couldn't have done any better
like I the proudest thing I've ever done
I wasn't proud at the time I didn't know
what pride was but now like I nailed it
and I went from drug addict Shevin if
anyone is listening this the new Chevy
rough in the city knows what I'm talking
about I went from this guy with the
reputation to BBC one you know I got to
go and I put my fingers up if you're
listening to this like I've got to go
like that to the world right that
recruiter Rumi was like look I'm top of
the board this month shut your mouth
right that's what I got and that's what
I've been bred on so I got to do that
but at that moment when everyone was
telling me how proud they were
my mum was finally proud of me everyone
was I took my first antidepressant pill
and the the second thing on that is I
was three months of marrying my
beautiful wife I'd built the career I'd
wanted I created the persona and status
I'd wanted the identity that I wanted in
life and I'd found the woman of my
dreams you know and was getting all this
praise and social media and news
articles and and asked to do bigger
projects and all this kind of stuff
everyone wants more podcast like I got
there but I was at the lowest point in
my life
why so there's two things here and and I
talked about the physiological and
psychological which you know I talked
about physiology is psychology but for
this conversation I separate the two
from a psychological perspective I went
into this project and I'd never really
confronted my own mental health I came
out of City quit drugs and just rolled
into starting a new business building a
business hustling fifteen hours a day
trying to make my name eight-way in the
world and you know I did that and I
never really dealt with a lot of the
gremlins I never had therapy to quit
drugs I never went to naa I would never
went to NA or anything like that like I
just dealt with it all myself and then I
went into the project where weekend day
in and week out I was talking to people
about their mental health you know we're
two experts and Piatt that I was quite
every time I went to go coach someone
I'd have a camera on me asking me what's
going on another camera afterwards
they'd be filming me having a
conversation and when I worked with
runners I didn't give a crap about the
running I cared about everything else in
their life that's what you focus on as a
coach right so for me I was getting into
this narrative mental health and
combining that with the physiological of
a state of chronic stress because I had
just been on for my whole life I'd only
ever lived in first gear I was wired I
was in a state of you know fight flight
and freeze at a sympathetic tone my
nervous system was just on all the time
and I never dealt with the gremlin so I
actually started going into therapy to
deal with some of the psychological
stuff halfway through filming it was
through the ferret therapy that I
realized that the reason I was ready so
it was a we said to know what it's like
a therapist like it just you know so I
went to go see her once a week the most
amazing thing the best thing that I ever
did you know
everyone has an assumption or will have
an image over the head of what that
actually looks like because a film was
nothing like that but was that literally
you sitting down and she would go Chevy
how are you feeling today what's me yeah
wasn't quite like you know it is it's a
you know I think might wasn't my visual
aid I always think Tony Soprano definite
Oni soprano but you kind of just go in
and you sit opposite someone and we sat
and she you know how and she just very
good at like you know what's gone on
this week and getting feelings out of
you without directly attacking them you
know and what she realized made me
realize and when you get quite serious
for a second and and everyone I hope
hope take this in a positive way so what
I realized within that therapy was so I
used I just poem by don't deal and
Thomas which I always plagiarize even
though it's the thing that saved my life
essentially which is he talks about rage
rage against the dying of the light do
not go gentle into that good night ray
and rage rage against the dying of the
light is a bit of a sentence that just
saved me right I never wanted to let the
light die within me I always wanted to
fight against it and she said to me like
why are you always fighting why is it
such rage against the light and then she
was like you know it we came out like
why are you always running all the time
why he was going from meeting to meeting
why are you never switching off why is
your day RAM packed why do I want to get
up from a dinner table by the time I put
the last bit of food in my mouth why
could I never spend time at but alone by
myself
why was I always running away and the
thing that we worked out with in therapy
is the reason that I was always moving
all the time
is because if I stopped I was gonna have
a conversation with suicide and that's
what therapy helped me figure out is I
was literally raging against the dying
of the light like I actually kind of
realized what that actually meant you
know at the same time I'd set up a
running crew called chasing lights like
oh is that all these signals were in my
life like kind of there and for me I
realized that I was moving and when it's
really funny because I was like no I was
never good I would never kill myself
because you know whenever I feel like
stood by the platform waiting for the
train and I've thought about jumping in
front of there it doesn't mean I would
actually do it but I was standing there
having that conversation what if
you know please if anyone else is this
is kind of it a deep subject there is a
lot you can speak to calm charity
they've got help lines there you can
reach out to me in Hisham will point you
in the right direction I appreciate it's
quite a punchy conversation but if we're
going to talk about this we have talked
about the truth about it it's and that
was it and that I realized that I was
and honestly rode to be by yourself I
was too afraid to be myself and it was I
which is always moving away and running
away from the darkness within me and it
was really gone just on that lot are we
talking justice or hope for men it's a
bit more like we talking not literally
so yeah that makes complete sense by the
way I get out I think a lot of people
probably might find themselves in the
same boat right always yeah hundred
miles away and that's because yeah as
you said you didn't face the demons and
that was the sort of you recognize that
but so like what are you talking about
literally like if you stopped or you'd
wasn't doing that that you like you
would literally be having the ideation
of clean yourself like are we talking
like this you just fit you would just
then just think about it or I think it
would crop up into my psyche like every
now and then like I'd always have these
like well what if I was better off on
this planet I'd be better off without
not just not being on this planet like I
would have these conversations and
myself but I would say it was more I
just there's a reason we put pod car you
know earphones in our heads all the time
we turn the TV on we're more at home
like I just never wanted to really deal
with what I had to deal with in my head
and I think that's what was it and I
think the more that I stopped and slowed
down the more that the inbox that I had
been ignoring would come flooding back
at me and there'd be 10,000 emails and
when I'm trying to fit like go through
there's 10,000 emails of all my past
experiences and traumas and problems and
issues it can get so overwhelming that I
think you know what instead of dealing
with that may be the best thing to do is
you know just you know whatever it may
be and that's the thing like it just
remember the brains default mode is
social cognition and I never really
understood never gave myself time to
process the life that I had been through
I had just I had replaced alcohol and
drugs with healthier things but I was
still running hard all the time chasing
pb's chasing times injuring myself all
the time
staying busy all the time like I just
replaced one with the other and
ultimately I hadn't dealt with the
things that I needed to deal with I
never dealt with the intrinsic things
inside
that were driving these behaviors so it
gave me an opportunity to have those
conversations to understand it and then
over the last few years has been about
just then kind of building on top of
that and now you see you realize that
when the BBC program launched and
obviously halfway through you are
getting the therapy so that must have
been really conflict and then in the
hard right because you're getting all
this praise you're going Chevy you're
done they're amazing blah blah blah but
and then you know behind closed doors
you'll having real conversations with
yourself and that those yeah those
moments a real hardship to process why
the fact I feel like this and having
that realization so how how did you how
did you start processing the demons you
know I went back to how I quit the drugs
which was just and this is really cheesy
it one one day at a time you know and
and I I learnt to slow down I learned to
find what third and fourth gear felt
like you know and then I educated myself
and that's how I ended up being here you
know I I i started to look I mean I'm in
the performance breath coach underneath
it all like I do a lot of work around
performance breath work and and
understanding off physiological response
around stress and state control I do all
these like look at the physiology and
for me I just started to focus on today
I didn't want to stay on medication
there's nothing wrong with medication
medication was the thing that gave me
the trampoline to look into the next
room but I was about to get married and
it was very hard for me to do what I
needed to do in the bedroom on medicate
medications like you know I was on the
money for six months and and that was
one of the side effects and for me you
know that just didn't sit well with me
so I started to understand like what is
the toolbox that I have you know I know
that you know we know that one hundred
and forty-five minutes of walking in a
week has similar mental health benefits
as antidepressants for some people we
know that I think it's not saying like
30% of people don't respond well to
typical antidepressants but there are
other antidepressants nature walking
exercise journaling talking so for me I
started to explore what the lifestyle
choices that I need to make what is the
toolbox that I have and I made my world
very small I said no to a lot of
business I let go of a lot of people
coaching wise I kind of shrunk
world to be able to just focus on me
today
you know and I learned to put my own
oxygen mask oh and I learned how to
educate myself I surrounded myself by
good coaches good thinkers you know I
choose I started to choose what I was
ingesting as much as my social media was
taking off I started I closed it all
down I stepped away from social for it
for over a year
you know I went into the shadows again
to just kind of start to kind of spend
time on me and evolve me and and work on
me and I looked at the energy
requirements of life and the reason I'm
a coach now is because of that journey
so dude I just broke it down one day at
a time and just built from there so
during that during that process then
what what sort of habits and
non-negotiables do you have now that
came from that process and journey god
this is a wonderful horror horror
workshop we get we can do bro like you
know for me I you know built some very
hard so just very simple things like and
again guys like I don't want to say I
have the perfect like no no but you know
some days like my habits go out the
window but for me you know it comes down
to some very basic things so first of
all was prioritizing always is
prioritizing sleep and sleep is the gift
that helps just process everything like
it is the most fundamental thing we need
to process thoughts feelings emotions
and set us up for tomorrow so that's
like you know understanding how to
manage my sleep better ensuring that I
do things like no screen light before
sunlight so making sure that I don't
just get up and get on my phones in the
morning make sure I wake up for an hour
I have my morning routines and habits
walking is king so making sure that I am
just consistently walking as much as
possible and getting outside into nature
as much as possible and closing down
stress and energy cycles you know if I'm
like right now you know what am I going
to do off this podcast is I'm not going
to jump into my emails and the next bit
of work I'm gonna go for a walk for half
an hour I'm gonna read for ten minutes
and then I'm gonna crack on it could be
much more effective in that next hour as
opposed to me trying to work for the
next two hours so it's kind of for me
it's understanding how to manage my time
to prioritize energy and focus and then
that's nutrition it's sleep it's walking
and then it's breath work as well I do a
lot around breath work breath work is
the gateway to better influence our
system and in so many different ways so
were kind of like the tools that I kept
picking up and an education dude keep
learning keep reading keep talking and
go from there
yeah I think the self education piece is
interesting and a real important one
because I've been on my own sort of
journey with that and by no means expert
but who even is an expert right but I
think what's like you sort of go to to
solving sort of you can see someone
you're having conversations with someone
that sort of you can see they're sort of
open to that light or they're open to
sort of they're curious to write how can
I start taking control of my mental
well-being and things like that what's
your sort of go-to self education for
people so I think for myself it you know
I'm gonna kind of cop out for the very
quickly for the first couple of
sentences and say always the first point
of forethought is self education is I
need to make sure you can spend time by
yourself because where I process the
books that I read is not when I'm
reading them it's when I go for a walk
afterwards without anything in my ears
to think about it right like that's
where we make the adaptions that's where
our body learns it gets stronger it
grows you know if we go in the gym we
don't get stronger in the gym when we
tear the muscles we get stronger when
we've stepped away from the gym and got
a good night's sleep and put our state
and say rest so first of all you know if
you I don't want you just reading to
just distract yourself to make sure you
can assimilate that's that's kind of
step number one and step number two it
depends where people are in their
journey bro like I'm surrounded by books
in here so this is always like a
wonderful question cuz I'm like I think
for me it's depending on where they are
I mean look a couple of great books like
if you really want to if you're a dude
and you want to understand more about
your human nature and ego there's a book
called the laws of human nature by
Robert Greene which like he'll tell
stories of like Coco Chanel or other
really kind of important historical
figures and he'll tell their story and
then he'll talk about how that relates
to our own personality traits and it
really gets you to stare into the barrel
of like why you do [ __ ] as a human being
so that's a real wake up call it's quite
a big book but an easy read if most
people are trying to make change they
probably struggle with consistency and
if they're struggling with consistency
it's because they need to understand
stress and energy in their life so a
great book that kind of puts a lot of
the research and practical stuff into
good ways of doing things is a book
called the upside of stress Kelly
McGonigal so it just really helped
people how to reframe stress like stress
is the most wonderful and powerful tool
that we have to become a better
recruitment consultant a better lover a
bit of family member a bitl Barre
athlete
we need stress in our lives to adapt and
grow if you're struggling against your
head you know and like kind of having
the right kind of mindset there's a book
called mindsets by dr. Carol Dweck which
is a fantastic book which talks about
fixed versus growth mindset and how to
challenge yourself on that with some
great exercises I mean if you're really
struggling just to make the right kind
of habits and routines the Internet is
awash with this book right now
everyone's reading it but atomic habits
is great like if you want to understand
the power behind that the final book if
you want understand how all of these
things piece together in a great book
there's a book called willpower Roy f
Baumeister and this book really helps
understand how to have the willpower and
self-control to make change because if
you can understand how to harness
willpower and self-control you can make
so much happen and that's I mean I've
read this book a million times and it
really helped me so I hope that that's a
lot sorry but it really just depends
good one I'll put that links to them in
the episode notes I think that'd be a
good good thing to do I guess the only
one that I chuck in there just because I
found it super interesting and to be
fair it's just a huge self-education on
the actual whole landscape of mental
health and I recommend that the last one
was the lost connections by Johann Hari
in this room I would have had I would
have probably I think you're absolutely
right like you've recommended the best
book like absolutely like a story I know
yeah that'll really give you a real
understanding of and it's coming from
someone that's been on the journey and
even and just a note on that you know
obviously you're listening to the
podcast podcast on the market right now
but he's done so many like YouTube
videos and really like listen to him and
then if you like it it Prime's you for
the book and he talks a lot about a lot
the stories on podcast like you
absolutely know it broke great very
great recommendation so look coming to
the end here let us sort of tile it like
how what do you think
I guess just what's coming up for me
before we finish is like how I don't
know what how do you think I don't know
do you think things are gonna change or
I don't know where how can we how can
people listen and actually just sort of
really break this down again talking how
you have sort of really helped you is
day at a time life how can I start
taking actions you think to sort of wrap
this up if I'm listens this Condors has
really helped me above habla what now
listen listen listen to your instant
like the first step to change is
awareness right you've got to be aware
of where you are you know people are
going off and doing wim hof breath work
or down-regulation piece like you know
do you even know what that's doing to
your system like you've got to be aware
of where you are and your system is
right now don't wear nasubi a hard thing
to do so that's just about learning to
spend some time alone with yourself
throughout the day at the right kind of
times within a day and then by doing
that the supercomputer on top of your
head will start to help you understand
what you need to pay attention to you
know your inside view is is ready to
talk to you you know I need to get an
early night I'm exhausted I'm tired so
then it can start to give you some
things to action so it just genuinely
it's just that you know where do I start
what do I do just start spending some
time by yourself throughout the day at
lunch break in between meetings in
between a home and work and home and
start to listen to what's going on and
just listen without being judgmental do
you know what I mean like just see it as
an experiment see is your body providing
you data and information for you to
action upon and if you keep telling
yourself you need to get back to the gym
or you know go back to the gym but maybe
doing hit sessions five times a week
wasn't what you needed because that is
actually a stress and an already
stressed out system
maybe you're just saying you need more
movement in your life you need more
walking you need more you know maybe two
sessions in a week like downplay what it
is that they don't be so optimistic or
don't set your sights so high like just
listen to what you need and then kind of
break that down a little bit more and
starts just to look after the basics man
like nutrition sleep movement hydration
solitude time alone if you start to look
after those things you start to look
after the energy cord attached to the
supercomputer that supercomputer will
start to be able to tell you what you
need to do in life and help you navigate
some of the problems in life now I
really like that and I think it's I know
it sounds really simple spent on you
with yourself but actually be surprised
how difficult that is this book called
solitude right like and I most like I
could list you whole other books here on
solitude rest like yeah look at all the
great thinkers you know and and and
people that we all look up to inspires
the Albert Heijn Stein's the Franklin's
the Abraham Lincoln's a consistent theme
throughout them and also the operators
that I work with right top billa's CEOs
directors real players in the market the
thing that they do very well is
understand how to shift gears they
understand the importance of putting
themselves into a state of rest downtime
because that's where they start to get
access to the cognitive resources for
better decision making for more
strategic decision-making creativity
like it is that the most powerful tool
to productivity and yes it is so simple
and sometimes am I like oh I I want to
give him like think isn't that like the
golden thing like something really
magical is he really just recommending
time by yourself and walking yet day any
day yeah that's why I write the yeah I
think I was just gonna say like just
sort of so I've done that is like yeah
that's way more difficult than you think
and people listening will know that
because when you go for a walk we all
know how how difficult it is to go no
I'm going to leave my phone or yeah like
like there's so many things now and this
is awesome
of the challenge of this right there's
so many things right now that offer
escapism an author not having to look at
the demons or look at or have the
opportunity to process right and I think
nothing that's I love that advice
because it is it does actually take a
real conscious effort to be like I'm not
gonna listen to a podcast on this walk
I'm gonna leave my phone or whatever and
I couldn't agree more so the journey I'm
still young and sort of the journey that
I've been on is so the more and more I
become more comfortable in my own skin
and with my own company and these types
of things is really personally helped me
with things like my when I was younger
and probably not as self-aware like I
was so worried about other people's
opinions like that's all I cared about
and sort of the journey that I've been
on that's been one of the the things
that I've really sort of correlated with
the more time you have in yourself and
not yeah being more willing to spend
time with yourself
not having inputs and the things that
you're saying the more comfortable you
are with other people's opinions of you
and you and the comfort of yourself and
I think it's so important that you do
really try and work on yourself and be
more comfortable self because as you
said and I would I definitely feel that
it gives you so much more opportunity
and energy to give to everyone else and
everything else in your life that I can
agree that more loving clever man yeah
so look and as we finish this then and
obviously you're happy for people to
reach out spin to you yeah an IBM people
don't always just say is really it's
appreciate I might spark some thoughts
or you know and and some some things
within people and we can't let so many
gray areas or so much mental and
physical diversity out there like please
do reach out if you've got questions and
I can send some more readings and more
data some more than um tell people to
kinda like I can I've got a whole load
of information that can help and so
forth so please do reach out the final
question and what woody what shall be
most excited about post coded
professional personal I'm excited I'm
excited to get back in front of people
you know I think that so many coaches
you know rightly so are building online
businesses and and have done and online
products and that's gonna be a necessity
and we meet it you know I'm actually
fighting for how I can get back in front
of people in rooms you know because this
is such a complex conversation it
deserves to be had in front of people
and I also know that people are craving
human interaction engagement myself
included as much as I'm a you know like
my own isolation and time by myself so
for me I'm just excited about us
building a world that you know of just
building a business where I can get back
in front of people and get away from
these zoom calls you know not all the
time but doing that and that's Jenny
warming side is getting back into a room
with people yeah so let's find a
question if if Chevy ruff could
communicate to every single recruiter
out there they'd listen they take your
advice they'd implement it tomorrow
what would Chevy say to the people God
in how could we this podcast I'm not
gonna walk what I'm thinking I'm like
I'm happy with today and then this one
you know I think it's really I I kind of
when I speak to recruiters I tend to
speak to the young recruit is the
recruiters are still trying to find
their way in the world and trying to
find the purpose behind what they're
doing you know why am i putting more CVS
up on the board you know be sending CDs
out the door why am i doing more bidi
cause what's the [ __ ] point of this
you know I just don't connect with it
and I just try and get them to realize
that you might not have a career in
recruitment but everything that you do
today will be about building skill sets
and competencies that will lend itself
to whatever you choose to do down the
line you know and and when you start to
understand that that candidate not
calling you back is an opportunity for
learning when that BD call when that
hiring manager hangs up for you it's an
opportunity for learning everything that
you see is negative and horrible and
annoying is when you can start to
understand that that is a challenge and
an opportunity for growth and developing
your skill sets then a skill sets that
will not only lend themselves to your
future recruitment career but outside of
that the reason I got a job on the BBC
over GB Olympic coaches and I got the
job is because I manage the sales cycle
well from the moment that they called me
up and
started to bring me into the process my
follow-up emails building rapport
building relationships sending them
feedback after each stage and generally
just understanding how to communicate
more efficiently that got me there you
know and it's really important to
understand that everything that I do now
the way that I communicate is all
because of recruitment so next time
someone hangs up the phone instead of
being pissed off and calling them an A
and think about what if I learned what
can I take away and how can i integrate
this into the next phone call into next
week and so forth is a learning
opportunity that will take itself far I
hope that make this yeah so it's been an
absolute pleasure it's been a blast
thank you so much brother
[Music]